FRED SAUER: Welcome to
the Root Access show.
This is a show where
we discuss issues
that start ups face.
And today we're talking about
scalability issues.
How do you handle massive
amounts of traffic and large
numbers of users?
Today my guest Ben Kamens, who's
the lead engineer at
Khan Academy, joins
us for discussion.
Ben, for those who haven't heard
maybe you can tell us a
little bit about Khan Academy,
what your mission is and what
to do for your users.
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, absolutely.
So Khan Academy's mission
statement is to provide a free
world class education
to anyone, anywhere.
It's a large mission statement,
so we can't claim
that we do anything remotely
close to that yet.
But we are trying.
I guess the simple breakdown of
what we do is anybody can
come to the Khan Academy site
and hopefully try to learn
anything, but right now it's
really about learning math and
some other things like
art history and
other stuff like that.
So when somebody comes to our
site they can interact with a
number of videos that
they can watch.
Some of those videos will ask
people questions to help
advance their understanding.
They can work through a
tree of math problems.
Like basically you could start
at 1 plus 1 and work your way
all the way down to calculus.
And the site should interact
with you and tell you what
you're succeeding at and what
you're failing at and
hopefully help guide you to
mastery of whatever you're
trying to learn.
That is the long term goal.
So that's kind of
the user side.
And then we have a story in our
classrooms where teachers
are actually using this with
lots of their students and
then using data that we give
them to learn more about how
their students are doing
in specific areas.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Great.
So maybe just a little bit of
context, how many users does
Khan Academy see?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, so I guess it
depends how you look at it.
I think right now Google
Analytics has us around five
or six million per month.
Registered users, I'm not sure
what the total number is now.
It's somewhere in the--
it's definitely in
the millions.
I'm not sure how many.
It's over five, less
than 15 million.
Somewhere in there users.
FRED SAUER: So you have a lot
of recurring users, then?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, yeah.
Hopefully more and more
as time goes on.
We're trying to build a site
that brings people back.
Yeah.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Maybe tell us a little
bit about how you got
to that many users.
Obviously you started with 0
users and then you started to
see your application grow, your
site traffic grow, and
then at some point, presumably,
you ran into the
first scalability issues.
And maybe tell us a little bit
about that and how you
addressed any problems
that you saw.
BEN KAMENS: Yeah.
It's kind of actually an
interesting story even from
before anybody joined Khan
Academy and it was just Sal
Khan making his videos.
Because he knew from the
beginning that he wanted an
interactive part of his site,
but then he started making
videos to complement the
interactive part.
So just as an example, he had
some math problems that he
would have people work on
interactively and then he
built videos to help people
understand how to do those
math problems.
So the result of that in terms
of scalability effect is that
his videos started to
get really popular.
And they were hosted on YouTube
and nobody has to
worry about scalability
on YouTube.
You guys take care
of that, right?
So YouTube scaled and he got a
whole bunch of users watching
the videos.
And then he started playing
more people at the site.
And this was before it
was on App Engine.
It was on some self hosted Java
thing and basically as
soon as he started pointing his
big audience to that site
there were DB connection
failures and all
this various stuff.
And so he, again, back when
it was just Sal, switched
everything to App Engine
because, I think, different
than a lot of start ups he
immediately had an audience
waiting from having built
it on YouTube.
So he basically switched
this audience.
It wasn't huge.
It wasn't in the millions,
but at least
tens, hundreds of thousands.
So he switched the code over to
App Engine, pointed users
at that, and then was able to
start slowly building the
foundation of a non YouTube site
that could handle some of
the traffic.
So that's the really
early story.
Then after that we basically
just kept growing.
It's gotten a lot of press and
a lot of attention over time
and so it's kind of just
naturally snowballed.
FRED SAUER: So taking that, if
you were there in the very
early days even before kind of
pointing more users to the
site, what would you have
done differently?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, that's
a great question.
So I think Sal learned his
lesson really early.
I don't think it makes sense for
any start up to not be on
some provider like App Engine or
EC2 or whatever is going to
solve a lot of the scalability
problems that you don't want
to solve by having your
own servers, I think.
That's just a no brainer
these days.
And that way if you get picked
up and you get a lot of
attention early, whether it's
from having a lot of videos or
from getting blog attention,
you have a chance to scale
immediately.
Just by throwing more money at
the problem, that's something
that you want to
be able to do.
So I think that's kind of--
if you're not doing that the
rest of my advice probably
won't be much use to you.
That's kind of step one.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So you talked about a couple
of technology options.
How does the technology
that you choose affect
your ability to scale?
Obviously if you're just renting
virtual machines you
can get more of them, but does
that address your scalability
or are there other dimensions to
the choice that are really
important to get right?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, there are
certainly other dimensions.
And people have solved this
other ways, in various ways.
I think there's obviously a
spectrum of how much of a
scalability solution you get
out of the box from whoever
you're working with.
And it's basically a spectrum
of how much control do you
want versus how much immediate
scalability do you want.
And the more control you get,
the more you're likely to have
shot yourself in the foot or
to not configure something
correctly and get
something wrong.
So I would say a service like
App Engine gives you tons and
tons and tons of scalability
right out of the box.
And as long as your credit
card's plugged in you're not
going to have many scalability
problems.
A service like Amazon services
can be similarly great.
But depending on how you
configure them you need to be
a little more on your game and
have a little bit more
awareness of how to roll up
instances and all the various
tricks that you have
to know on AWS.
And so they're both great
solutions in my opinion.
Perfectly legitimate for
any start up to choose
either one right now.
But there are definite trade
offs in terms of how much time
you have to focus on the
scalability solution.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Now, with scalability.
There's kind of another
dimension that I think
sometimes early start ups forget
to look at or they may
imagine they'll deal with it
later, which is kind of the
availability of the
application.
So they start out hosting,
whether it's their own servers
or in a data center somewhere,
they're in one place and then
when they realize that they need
some redundancy for data
center failures or network cuts,
they suddenly need to
figure out how to replicate
their data across regions.
Is that something you've had
to deal with at all?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, so we
can luckily say no.
That and many other things
because we went the more
automatic route and the using
App Engine route.
That's all kind of taken
care of for us.
So thanks to your team we've
never, let alone worried about
replication, we've never
restarted a server on instance.
We don't carry pagers.
That has enormous benefit for a
team that's trying to focus
on a specific hard problem like
educational technology.
We don't want to restart
servers.
We want to talk to teachers.
So that has an enormous impact
on how our ability to focus on
the problem at hand because
we're not worried about that
sort of thing.
So while I wish I could give
more actionable advice there,
I have to be honest, I'm
not an expert at all.
But that's the whole point.
FRED SAUER: That's a
great thing about
not restarting servers.
And everything that comes along
with that, like not
applying OS patches, not
worrying about those software
installs and upgrades.
It's your application code that
you want to worry about,
because that's where
you're at.
BEN KAMENS: Yep.
I mean, it's an abstraction over
all that stuff so you can
focus on the business.
All abstractions leak.
Nothing is perfect.
You're going to have to deal
with problems no matter what
you choose.
We chose a higher level
of abstractions.
It's paid off pretty
well so far.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Well, so on this theme of
scalability, many start ups,
at some point, experience
this TechCrunch effect.
They get posted on a prominent
blog and suddenly the traffic
just goes through the roof.
Are there other things start
ups can do to take care of
that or should they just cross
their fingers and hope it'll
all be fine?
BEN KAMENS: That's
a great question.
So our big experience with
this is 60 Minutes.
So we've been featured on a lot
of blogs, a lot of things
like TechCrunch, Reddit,
Hacker News,
all that stuff, right?
All of that traffic combined
doesn't even come close to
what 60 Minutes delivered
when they featured us.
It wasn't even close.
It's a different sort of
traffic, right, it's all--
we can cut this out-- it's
all Internet Explorer.
It's a different sort
of traffic.
But 60 Minutes delivers
a lot of traffic.
And so we've been on
a couple times.
The first time we basically knew
that there was going to
be a lot of traffic and were
prepared to turn the right
dials in App Engine so that we
can get more instances easily.
And we did that.
But other than that we were kind
of crossing our fingers.
And that was a mistake.
I do think we have actionable
advice to give after that.
The mistake was that while we
were prepared to turn the
right dials we hadn't really
simplified the experience that
people were going to get.
So as a result, we were doing
a whole lot of work that
didn't need to be done
for every user.
A very specific example is we
thought oh cool, we're getting
all the 60 Minutes traffic.
Let's for the first time ever
run an AB test on our home
page and track all the data
that comes with that.
With our custom AB solution.
Which was a terrible mistake,
a really stupid mistake.
And the actionable advice that
we should have taken, which we
took for follow up 60 Minutes
pieces, was the main
experience that all that traffic
is going to go to,
just make sure it's
clean and simple.
And if you have to track data,
make sure it's important data
that you're tracking and that
that's a well tested data
tracking solution.
And that you're not running code
you don't need to code
for all that traffic that's
going to be kind
of a one time spurt.
Because you only get that thing
one time and if, like
us, half of the East Coast feed
can't access the site
because you tried to track
too much data,
that's not worth it.
So for the West Coast feed and
for the all follow up 60
Minutes pieces we basically
said, all right, look, the
homepage is just going to
be as static as we can
make our home page.
It's simple.
It loads quickly.
People who branch off from that
can get the rest of the
experience but let's
just simplify for
the incoming traffic.
FRED SAUER: So what about
load testing?
Is that something you've done
up until that point?
Is it possible that even
predicted what
scale, what type of--
what load testing advice
can you give?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, that's
a good question.
So we haven't done enough
load testing.
We thought from all of our
previous press pushes that we
had from the spikes that we've
seen that we had enough.
We had no idea how
much traffic 60
Minutes would give us.
And we hadn't tested
that amount.
So if you can test the right
amount, then do it.
We are fortunate enough to
be, again, sorry for not
actionable advice, but we're
fortunate enough to be a
situation where the traffic
is pretty high
consistently, we think.
It's also tends to be a little
bit spiky consistently due to
people using really heavily
during school.
And it's also pretty seasonal.
So it tends to stress our
systems in a good way and that
we have to be able to handle
spikes and valleys and we have
to build a handle months where
it's really active and then
December where it's not
very active at all.
And so I think that has helped
us balance things a little bit
more because we know we need to
configure our code in App
Engine right to be able
to handle that spike.
So our load testing has been
a little bit more natural.
I guess my actionable load
advice here is we got away
without doing a ton of it.
But it's probably smart
to do more of it.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So how early on should
start ups worry about
load testing and scale?
Should that be something they
think about out of box or is
it just a select few who know
they're going to be very
popular out of the gate?
And how do you divide
up the work?
Do you have a dedicated
scalability team and then
people working on features?
Or does everyone need to think
about scalability?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, so I'll tell
you what we did, which was
basically try not to worry
about it at the start by
offloading as much work as
you can to somebody else.
Which in our case is you guys.
And that was huge.
That lasted until we had around
nine or 10 employees.
And at that point we felt like
when we hit performance
problems it was no longer
acceptable to basically just
patch over it and hope
it goes OK next time.
And so at that point, and
obviously still start up size
but a little bit bigger than two
or three people, at that
point we were willing to say
for your quarter these two
people are just focused on
performance and build
dashboard so we can predict
problems ahead of time and try
to be a little bit more
proactive about our
performance issues and our
scalability issues and
tracking all that information.
So for us that was around
nine or 10 people.
It really depends, I guess, on
the problem solving and how
much traffic you know you're
going to immediately get.
I would say that's not what you
want to be doing when you
are a two to five person
organization.
There are too many ways to have
somebody else solve that
problem for you or some other
system worry about scalability
than for you have to
focus on that.
FRED SAUER: So it's really
focus on the features and
capabilities that are behind
your start up.
BEN KAMENS: Make your
start up great.
Make your product great.
Get users coming back to it.
And then you can over engineer
all you want once you've got a
successful business.
If you do that ahead of time I
think you're shooting yourself
in the foot.
It's too easy to use App Engine
or EC2 or whatever it
is that's going to solve
these problems for you.
Because nobody's paying--
your site needs to
stay up, period.
Get something that stays up
and then worry about the
problems when you have
a chance to build
a successful product.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So in the division of labor when
you were at that nine or
10 people, did everyone
focus on scalability?
Or did you have like a SWAT team
that kind of dealt with
the problems?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, so we have
on our list of things that
people are working on at the
very top is one that's not
assigned to anybody and it says
performance is-- it's
something, performance is
everyone's job and it's just
everybody's assigned to it.
So we do require and we try to
build a culture of awareness
of performance, which is a
necessary thing to do because,
as you know, once you have a
performance problem somebody's
going to be the hero by solving
the 80% problem and
that goes out of the way.
And after that it's a game of
1%, 1%, 0.5%, 0.25%, 0.25%.
That's the only way to
get to a faster site.
And it is great to have people
dedicated to that.
But at the same time, if you
have a bunch of people who are
just throwing extra JavaScript
in every minute or adding new
database queries, whatever
they're doing is just going to
slow your site down.
So we try to build performance
awareness into the entire team
and then we basically have had
quarters where a one or two
person team is solely focused
on proactive performance
improvement, whether that takes
the form of actually
changing our code to make it
faster or building tools so
that we are more aware of
our own performance.
FRED SAUER: So can I imagine
that more as kind of a
dedicated fix it?
Like where we're going to set
some time aside, not stop
features entirely, but we're
going to focus on scalability
for a week for a month, for a
quarter, something until we
get back on track?
BEN KAMENS: We've basically done
that for a quarter with
small teams.
And I love the idea.
We have stolen Google's
idea of fix its.
So we haven't had a performance
fix it yet but I
think that's an awesome idea
whether it's a day or week.
Basically you're going to get
big wins when you focus on
performance.
And even more importantly,
you'll build that culture into
your team, a culture of
caring about speed.
And so I guess, yeah, the
fix it's a great idea.
FRED SAUER: As you've grown
through kind of the different
levels of scale when you go 10x
from your initial size and
then 100x and 1,000, have you
gotten to a point where you
said, OK, we need to kind of
re-architect either our data
store or the way we store and
access data for more efficient
patterns or fundamentally
change the
way the code behaves?
Or has it always grown
organically in kind of very
small step function,
worked its way up?
BEN KAMENS: It grew organically,
I would say, for
about a year and a half.
And then we got to the point
where you have to fix some of
the underlying issues.
We certainly haven't
fixed them all.
But some of the big ones that
we've started to address, and
I guess some of the pain points
that got most painful
for us, were that we're
collecting all this data and
more and more users are coming
and we're getting
more and more data.
In our case, we wanted to report
a lot of that data to
teachers or to other people.
So now after a year of
a classroom of--
or a couple classrooms of 100
kids using the site every day
in school it's tons and tons of
data for us to analyze and
present to the teacher
in a nice way.
And so our old data storage
system was unable
to report on that.
And so we had to basically
go back and rethink.
We need to do it again.
But we had to go back and
basically rethink how we
summarize all this data, how
we accumulate it over time,
start rolling things up, and
basically follow Google's
principles of do a whole bunch
of work when writing the data
so that reading the
data is fast.
We had to basically build that
belief into our team of
re-architect data, copy it
everywhere, make it really
fast to analyze later.
And that took a lot of
learning for us.
Transparency, we're
still not there.
But we've started
to re-architect
things and do better.
FRED SAUER: So it's an
ongoing process?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
If you have advice.
You guys always have great
advice for us.
FRED SAUER: I think you're
taking the right approach.
I think you have to spend a
certain amount of time.
And then while you can't throw
it all away because you have a
live website and you have
changes that you're making, I
think occasionally you do need
to dedicate some time and say,
OK, let's fundamentally change
the way we do something.
But in a controlled fashion.
So you have traffic
that's 24/7.
People are using the site
and you don't want--
I always chuckle a little bit
when I try to make a deposit
in my bank.
I look at my bank account and
the bank website is down for
four hours a night doing
some batch processing.
This feels like I'm
still in the '60s.
And so doing things in the live
system is a little bit
like doing maintenance
on an aircraft while
it's in the air flying.
Something you can do, but it
takes a certain amount of
discipline.
But you can do really
interesting things.
Because you never
stop, so you're
never losing that momentum.
BEN KAMENS: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
And it's really related to your
previous question about
how much do you immediately
focus on this stuff.
Because there's no point in
obsessing over that hard
problem of building another
airplane if your first
airplane isn't already really
in the air and flying.
So waiting until you definitely
need this feature
and everybody's demanding it
before you spend a whole bunch
of time coming up with the nice
data architectures is
really important.
FRED SAUER: So then, taking the
analogy there, it's like
get your aircraft in the air,
and then worry about making it
pretty and perform later.
BEN KAMENS: Use somebody
else's engines.
Get it up there.
FRED SAUER: Maybe
an App Engine.
Great.
A lot of companies are talking
about a new type of
organization in your company
called DevOps.
The developer operations.
And it's kind of merging
with IT operations.
Is DevOps something
you subscribe to?
Is that a term you use
at Khan Academy?
BEN KAMENS: It's not a term
we use right now.
Again, I'll be honest and be
clear when I'm not an expert.
I'm definitely not
an expert here.
It is something that I was
familiar with in my previous
job when we weren't using a
cloud provider, whatever you
want to call it.
And it was obviously
extraordinarily important.
Right now our team a small
enough, still around 15, 16
engineers, for everybody
to be kind of a dev.
And everybody's responsible
for keeping the site up.
I could see a time when we
have accumulated enough
specific systems that are
outside of App Engine that
will require other people, our
time, to make sure they're
perfectly optimized and
they're working well.
We're not there right now.
We've so far benefited from
just kind of sticking with
mostly just App Engine.
FRED SAUER: OK.
So maybe in parting you
can leave kind of--
if you have one piece of advice,
something, a kind of
wisdom that you want to
pass on to start ups.
And it doesn't have
to be one thing.
But what would you tell the
would be start up that--
what advice would
you give them?
BEN KAMENS: Yeah.
I certainly won't claim to
know everything here.
But I guess if I were going back
I would encourage myself
to just keep things really,
really simple.
Both technically and
in your product.
Keep things simple until you
know absolutely what you need
to build and then build
that thing.
And most of the pain
we've caused
ourselves has been from--
not most of the pain, but a lot
of the pain we've caused
ourselves-- have been from these
various things that we
built at one time to help
somebody in some edge case and
it turns out that thing can
cause a real problem for
everybody else in some way.
And it's hard to turn things
off once you build them.
So I guess just kind of
keep things simple.
Build what you need
and go from there.
FRED SAUER: That seems like
really good advice.
Don't build anything
unless you have to.
Really [INAUDIBLE].
BEN KAMENS: And take as
much work as you can
have somebody else.
We are shamelessly lazy and
willing to benefit from other
people's work where possible.
There are so many free tools
and non free tools that are
totally worth the money that are
great out there right now.
So fight the tendency to build
everything in house.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Fight the natural engineering
tendency.
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, at least
until-- yes, exactly.
It is a natural tendency.
And it's a natural tendency
to kind of not trust other
people's code and want to
code your own stuff.
That's great and there's totally
valid reasons for
that, especially once your
business is doing really well.
But until then, just--
FRED SAUER: Keep it simple.
BEN KAMENS: Yeah.
Use other people's work.
FRED SAUER: Great.
Well thanks, Ben.
BEN KAMENS: Yeah, thanks.
And thanks to your team
for everything.
FRED SAUER: Thanks
for tuning in.
This was a episode
of Root Access.
Check the schedule to see what
episode is next and what
topics we'll cover.
Thanks for tuning in.